Bởi bởi môi sống chính xe khủ trợ đống mà hình xa hội.
Bởi bởi môi sống nhóm đối tượng như người là động Việt Nam đi làm việc ở nước ngoài thông đồng.
Và họ trong đi theo thành viên cơ quan đại diện Việt Nam ở nước ngoài,
chủ hộ kinh suanh của đang kinh suanh,
người quan lý sân nghiệp, kinh suáp viên, người đại diện phần bố nhảnh hấp.
Họ phần bốn của suanh nghiệp không hưởng tìl luôn.
Bởi bởi môi sống đều chính xam dần đổi tội rửa chợ cấp luôn chỉ xa hội.
Sống đồ bài mi tùa ý thư dụ khiến phát triển tình tế xa hội.
Và khả năng tên đối nha sách tưởng thời ký.
Đông thời điều chính thên lương làm cân của đồng bảo hiểm xa hội bất bộ.
Để tính mức bình quan tên luôn, làm cơ sở tính lương hư,
chựa các bảo hiểm xa hội.
Đối với người đồng thuốc của bởi mường lương tư chỉ đồng của nhà nước.
Bất kện gạo để mừng giấm sĩ mắc phủ bảo hiểm xa hội.
Dưa thảo để sống hiến tưởng mở giọc đối tượng,
tham xa bảo hiểm xa hội bất bộ.
Đối với người làm việc thông đồng dưới một tháng.
Người làm việc không trọng thời gian và một số nhóm nó đậm có thu nhập.
Thông qua nên tàng số ứng dụng công nghệ.
Khiệ bộ tay chính nghiệm, cắn nước có khoảng 2 mai chủ người tham gia bảo hiểm xa hội.
Đà thân bống lắm phần chăm được gửi ở lau đồng trong đựa tuổi.